it's easy enough to say i'm going to
start learning this language but i know
from experience it's a lot of work hi
there steve kaufman here today i want to
sort of ask myself a question
why do you want to learn another
language
and
but first before i get into the subject
uh if you enjoy my videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a review
so
why has this subject suddenly come to my
mind well
my a large part of my inspiration for
learning languages comes from
different series that my wife watches on
netflix and i kind of go in and out of
the tv room and sometimes sit down and
watch
and she was watching an
indian movie
gangubai or something
uh and of course it's it's in bombay
it's 100 years ago or whenever 80 years
ago and it's very exotic and all of
these things that sort of
you know and of course
i pick out the odd word
in hindi that sounds a bit like persian
the odd one
and it then becomes very tempting to say
you know what i should learn
hindi or punjabi or one of those indian
languages
and so then i say to myself well here
you are you've been struggling with
persian and arabic and of course
neglecting other languages that you've
learned
why would you take on yet another
language
and
you know this is an interesting question
obviously the more languages you have
or the more languages you try to learn
the less well you're going to speak in
languages that you have already spent
time trying to learn
you know
i sometimes say to myself why did you
ever bother trying to learn
persian and arabic when you know i maybe
you should
focus on korean which is not at a level
that you would like
and the the simple answer is
that i'm always curious
you know as imperfect as my arabic and
persian are and i will may perhaps do a
uh
maybe a conversation with my tutor again
in those languages and you'll see that
it's full of holes and yet
it's at a level where i enjoy them
uh i enjoy listening to my um you know
radio fardo
podcast news in farsi i understand a
fair amount of it
i enjoy for example my jordanian
cartoon series so i'm enjoying
participating to some extent in that
language in that culture however
imperfectly
so
whatever i put in
i feel i get back
now
how exciting would it be to have some
sense
of how
some indian language works
probably hindi because it's the most
widely spoken and of course the
bollywood movies are in hindi
but here in vancouver most of the people
from india are in fact from the punjab
so they speak punjabi
probably i have no idea how mutually
intelligible those languages are but
it would be fun
to do them and so it becomes fun
it's it's a challenge like part of
learning other languages simply because
the language is there
so it's like why do you climb a mountain
because the mountain is there
you know i look back to when i wrote my
book the linguist on language
i guess i was 57 or so
and i had nine languages and i had
enjoyed every one of those nine
languages well now i'm
approaching my 20th language
mostly since the age of 60
and it's brought me so much and i can
think of the
the egyptian movies that i watch trying
very hard to understand something not
understanding too much but
but because of my exposure to that
language and the few things that i do
understand i'm more involved i i can
feel and smell and touch the culture
more
uh similarly with
persian where
sahara in iran has sent me some
iranian movies and i'm confident maybe
more confident in persian than in arabic
that i'll eventually be able to
understand those movies quite well
uh so it brings me all of that and and i
think i've made the point in a number of
my other videos that whatever i achieve
is good it's all a plus there is no
negative
perhaps the only negative is that i
haven't spent that time working on some
of my other languages
but i can go back to them whatever i put
into them is there i'm not going to lose
it it might take me a little while to
refresh them
so
i don't know why learn another language
i guess the question can be asked of
someone like me who has tried to learn
say 20 languages
and who might look at trying to
learn about another yet another language
or two or three
or someone who is still struggling with
their first foreign language and of
course for many people it's not a hobby
for many people it's it's there's a
practical need
they might be an immigrant or a refugee
in a country in germany or in north
america or somewhere they have to learn
the local language
or
if you're living somewhere where you do
business with people from another
country and you need that language then
of course there's a greater sort of need
for the language
but i'm not in that situation i'm in the
situation where i
learn languages for pleasure
and uh why would i take on yet another
language with all of and of course it's
easy enough to say i'm going to start
learning this language but i know from
experience it's a lot of work so once i
commit myself to sort of
spending time with that language
it's going to be another
sort of time sump
but
it's an enjoyable pursuit for me
and not only is the actual study of the
language enjoyable but everything that
comes with it the discovery of the
culture getting closer to those people
and seeing those people less sort of in
a caricature form or stereotype form but
rather seeing them as they are and
hearing how they speak and how they
express themselves so that's why i
continue to add languages although i
don't achieve a high level of fluency
i do achieve a very worthwhile level of
familiarity with those languages and and
that's why i would continue learning
languages and i would like to
suggest you have a look at two languages
or two videos that i did on the subject
uh one was six months ago where i talk
about learning two languages at once
and another one three months ago where i
talk about learning multiple languages
at the same time
and that might give you a little
different perspective on the issue of
taking on
uh different languages or continuing to
challenge yourself with more languages
when you already know some and and i'm
sure i'm not the only one in this
situation so i look forward to hearing
from you
bye for now